[Music]  you carry your gun mr. chase I never  bothered Bruins aloud your suit you used  to be a spy my child's the prisoner  $70,000,000 far they retake is by my  former father-in-law only buys the best  time for you to do whatever it is he  pays you to do hope you're half as good  as everything else exported believe  appender answer mr. Gailey do not have  the money to spare no one has ever been  richer than you are at this moment what  would it take for you to feel secure  more on your side  protect from every threat  unless the threat  and that leads to people  Oh Paul I didn't hire an F CIA officer  just to pay people off I hurt you the  two things other people can't or won't  do we have to be willing to walk away  it's my son I can't walk away  I don't think this is about money it's  about power power business  tell them I'm coming  you know  [Music]  you